good morning
Millennials welcome back to the toast
and happy Thursday hope everybody's
having a great day rip Theo how are you
rippity rip rip rippity rip wait can we
talk about something rip rip Rip r rip
rip rip rip yeah that first literally
this show is all about us talking about
some things so kick us off like Theo
died I know it hits me like that
sometimes too like
where it's like of course I know Theo is
no longer with us but then sometimes I
realize like Theo is no longer with us
right like he's not at his grandparents
like he's literally dead like what the
[__] he just like vanished poof unless
he's basement I who am I poof Theo
allegedly yeah unless he's a sex slave
in someone's basement sex slave
Dora sex slave Dora no I've I've made
peace like I I realized like those were
hallucinations like those were that was
my denial phase
totally yeah but actually a lot of
people message me like people who have
lost someone like humans dogs and
they're like we have this running joke
in my family CU we never saw you know
our grandmother's body that like she's
literally still alive like that okay I'm
glad I'm glad I wasn't the only one who
had that insane irrational fear yeah no
I think that's real you've got to see
the body you've got to get
confirmation I know you've got to
literally do a pulse check so now I know
the next time you know God forbid God
forbid Shalom like I lose someone I got
to do triple checks yeah just a little
you know and actually I learned how to
take someone's pulse I feel like people
just like put their fingers on their
necks and I'm like you're not feeling
like I never could figure it out and
then I recently not recently like a
couple years ago I went to a wedding um
it was like in a ski town so we were on
this Gondola and I was on the Gondola
with another wedding guest who was a
cardiologist and he just like I told him
I was like freaking out like about the
gondola and he took my pulse I'm like
Hey how do you do that and I figured it
out now it's actually much easier on the
wrist let's take my
pulse oh wait I lost it I always forget
I forget to breathe when I take my pulse
you should have a pulse even when you're
holding your breath okay I feel it I
feel it oh it's a kind of weird I don't
like that it is weird I don't feel mine
uh oh two fingers on your wrist like a
little bit lower than you would think
yeah yeah yeah I've got
some turty she's
dead
oh no call an ambulance call an
ambulance call an
ambulance you find it it's also hard to
like listen to someone talking a fun
fact about me is that I have a very low
pulse
like yeah when I go to the doctor like
it's it's low when oh Dr Fox called it a
runner's
pulse are you a runner she's a runner
she's a runner but I feel that way I
feel like I don't breathe unless it's
completely necessary you know you don't
you don't breathe unless told to I don't
take ex strenuous breaths like Ben takes
extren breaths I mean that's putting it
mildly I think Ben like breathes double
the amount that I
breathe it's like one of the meanest
things you could say to someone
really why but it's not you know I know
what you're saying but like the
implication is that it's just like this
gorilla like the thing is though he's
like spelt now and it's still true so
it's really not a weight thing
wait speaking of Ben I had my ski lesson
yesterday I know and speaking of Ben
it's because if you watch my Vlog on
patreon I really could not find anyone
to come with me and I was just like
nervous about driving there by myself
parking filming vlogging and learning to
ski all at the same time MH so Ben did
take me and he waited in the car which
was so nice the the Vlog was amazing I
don't want to spoil anything but I
vlogged my whole experience yesterday
driving out to New Jersey for a ski
lesson it's on patreon at patreon.com
toast but I want to talk about the ski
lesson because what I
did was shred some Nar it was I was
incredible now let me tell you skiing is
so hard yeah and I did they just kind of
like the best way to learn is sort of
like baptism by fire like they just kind
of send you down yeah and I didn't
really know and it's like you learn
slowly like I thought you just ski you
like Squat and you go like you just go
straight but if you do that like you go
so [__] yeah that's like what ski Racers
do if you want to right slow it down you
got to cut it up it's like sh boom boom
so I was learning that slowly over time
but there was one minute you know one
there was one run where they just
essentially throw you
down I would pay $10 million to have
watched myself on that thing like Jackie
I was screaming the fact that I didn't
fall is a miracle I was screaming Ethan
Ethan he was my instructor he was
amazing Ethan greater then Ethan greater
than I got the best possible instructor
and he was so down to be in my Vlog
which was so nice and he had Charisma
personality and he was a really great
instructor as seen in tur's new skills
also I feel like other people should go
take ski lessons at this small so what's
so funny is one of my best friends
Margo she is not a skier but she went
skiing like a couple of years ago with
her in-laws and she also took a lesson
before and she was she texted me she's
like wait are you going to the American
dream mall that's what I did I'm like oh
yes she honestly everyone should do it
before going on a trip because I have
taken a lesson on a mountain it's such
chaos and if you're going with a group
of people like I was like nobody wants
to wait with me with my lesson and then
I'm all alone like it kind of sucks so
preparing before now of course indoor
skiing is not the same as outdoor skiing
and the Big Run quote that I did is I
think probably one tenth of an actual
yeah Trail whatever you call it yeah but
and that's kind of what's freaking me
out is like okay I would go down this
run and it would take like 30 seconds
but a real run is what 10 minutes yeah
well the thing is the hardest part of
skiing I think once you know how to a
ski is when you're not on a run it's
walking over to the chairlift it's
waiting online and shuffling up and
using your sticks and navigating and
then getting on the chairlift which I I
don't want to spoil your video but the
chairlift imagine chairlift going up in
an actual down the chairlift is the most
horrible place on the planet I know it's
really not pleasant but there are there
are some chairlifts a lot of them
especially the runs that we do are
barebones chairlifts like what you did
one bar great but there are some chair
lifs especially where we're going to ski
where it's enclosed and it's
he was telling me about that and then he
was showing me pictures of the gondola
he went on in Alaska he's kind of like a
like a big time skier you have to be if
you're teaching ski lessons yeah so do I
feel prepared no am I more prepared yes
I might still do one more lesson when we
get there like yeah you should or take
the instructor with us that's the thing
I just want to have someone with me
because I felt so much peace I'm like
Ethan please just stay close to me yeah
cuz there was one time when like I
literally almost died and he like helped
me slow down having like a profession
nearby even if I don't like touch them
just knowing that they're there I think
would bring me a lot of Peace yeah you
should do that and that way we can all
meet like at the bottom of we we're not
all having to go at the same speed but
we actually meet incrementally
throughout the Run we don't all just
meet at the bottom like we'll stop well
I told Ben like he's not allowed to
leave my side I think being alone on the
mountain is the scariest part of course
you're we've never when I see with Ben
and Margo none of us are ever alone on
the mountain for more than like 3
minutes and then like there's at the end
of a a hill like we wait for each other
and then we continue going we should
just like kind of be Tethered to each
other which I know is like so dangerous
also so unsafe yeah that's no but then
you know you just think about like
skiing is so unnecessary like people die
skiing like why are we doing this for
the thrill of it I know but we're not
thrill seeking individuals no and the
way that we ski is not that thrilling we
only do green runs and we take it at our
own pace it's very leisurely but it's
Pleasant it's to be out in nature you
know to working your body it's like
working out while also taking in The
Great Outdoors so we don't really do it
for the thrill but we also don't really
ski in a way that's like really unsafe
competitive Ben did say it's like the
one thing you were missing that skiing
is all about is like you were inside so
there's no you know beautiful trees and
mountains and Vistas to look at so I am
looking forward to that yeah also the
run that I did Ethan said is like it's
like a it's considered a blue it's like
an easy blue but it's a blue so I'm not
going to do a blue I'm going to do the
easy one which is a green right yeah
yeah yeah we most so that's just like
more flat kind of yeah less steep less
twists and turns it's just the easiest
one okay so I feel like I overprepared
in a sense yeah for sure I think I saw
your footage you're ready you do you
think yeah you're ready for your first
day of skiing 100% yeah honestly it's a
great place to learn I think if I was
like an avid skier I wouldn't find those
facilities so much fun because and this
is what I was saying to Ethan and Ethan
was like that's the essence of skiing
it's a lot of work for a little bit of
fun like getting on the chair Air Lift
with the skis and the boots like it's a
lot of torture for like a small thrill
it is but at least for me the thrill and
the fun of it outweighs the torture
that's why we continue to do it that's
how fun it is because we know the
torture threshold is high yeah so I was
like dreading it all day but I ended up
having a blast I feel like I was it was
very successful and then I got to eat at
yard house afterwards which is honestly
so much better than Cheesecake Factory
like not enough people talk about that
what's Yard House I know so I only
discovered Yard House when I was on tour
because pretty much every venue like
they when you would like order dinner
Yard House was always an option I'm like
all Yard House yard and then I just
realized it's kind of like a BJ's Brew
House it's a chain but it's not as well
known as Cheesecake Factory it is so
much better nice what' you get aside
from fries I got chicken lettuce wraps
they were so good they were so and Ben
got AI tuna Taco nachos like yeah it was
so good and it was happy hours we got
like so many appetizers some Diet Cokes
and it was like $33 yum well I was also
watching your Vlog and it was making me
a little bit sad about this mall because
it's
like someone somewhere decided we're
going to spend all this money so that
people like get out there and have fun
and do activities and like live and
nobody this mall was built outside the
city a few years ago bu they built it
and we they did not come and it's sad
it's like okay so you could what sit on
your phone all day like go to the mall
go ski go to the water park like they're
trying to make real fun activities for
people and and the people said no thank
you there is a mall that's a few years
old some company spent a billion dollars
building this mall it's like Mr Beast
filmed a video there it's like this
insane Mall water parks indoor skiing
luxury shopping food court like it's
huge it's right by MetLife Stadium and
it was built for the people of New York
and New Jersey and I mean a mall at
Christmas time is pandemonium not the
one I was at last night like people like
just don't go to this mall yeah I guess
the time you know it's not Peak Mall
hours like between 300 and 5: on a
Wednesday so we'll give them a there but
it's like we no one I know really goes
you know it's not like we see tons of
stuff happening there I know Kim went
once she took her kids skiing yep
yep and hopefully this patreon gives
them a boost because from what I saw in
the Vlog I saw successful indoor skiing
I saw great instructors I saw a
beautiful ceiling that you were
constantly filming in front of I heard
Kelly Clarkson Underneath the Tree on
the soundtrack and I saw a gorgeous meal
and I can't even imagine what other
offerings there are there so get out
there and go to the mall of
Dreams American Dream Mall American
Dream mall like and a gorgeous
name I had a blast like no complaints
parking was $5 for a couple of hours
which was pretty reasonable like it was
good stuff and what town was it in East
Rutherford it's right next to MetLife
Stadium where the Jets Giants and play
far it's not that far if you can get to
a Jets game you can get to the
mall Aaron Rogers should go to the mall
if you can see the nid you can see the
ad Adam you could see the Adam for sure
Adam greater than n something to think
about something think about everyone go
check out that Vlog I hope you all
enjoyed it it's also just some a great
like Ben offer celebrity footage you
know listening to lonel Richie it's a
lot of tury and Ben we did a little
mukbang too cuz we went to Mrs Fields I
was so hungry after skiing like it's
really just so phys you work up an
appetite it's fun and then you eat on
the mountain they have like such good
food they better yeah they've got I mean
they have it all you get a little hot
cocoa but we always they have like fried
foods it's tasty tasty and some the only
thing is sometimes there's restaurants
at the top of the mountain middle of the
mountain bottom of that one usually and
so sometimes it's fun to eat at the top
of the mountain because it's really nice
views and everything but then you have
to ski down then you go down with a full
belly it's the hardest run no I would
never um a lot of people like ski in the
morning eat lunch and then ski in the
afternoon I've never successfully skied
post lunch like I need to be I need to
be empty I feel I feel that yeah but I'm
also a little nervous to ski this year I
haven't skied in two years which not
even that but I'm carrying a little
extra weight and I just hope that I'm
able to to get
around but you're carrying extra weight
because you gave birth to two human
beings and that gives you like more
superpowers like true and that's true
I'm not worried okay okay I I should be
okay but it's just like it won't be the
same exact like weight and feeling so
maybe we're on the same level now
perhaps yeah and it's you'll get on to
level pretty quickly cuz snitch and I we
don't really advance to the next level
because we don't challenge ourselves but
we're happy with that like it's enough
for us Di and then sometimes if we're on
a ski trip and like we've been doing the
greens for a few days maybe we'll try
one vot for like we're feeling crazy and
that's also enough for us Dian Ben told
me he went to Veil like before the
pandemic and he went skiing with his
friends and one of his friends is a very
good skier and they were on the
chairlift and one of his friends like
tricked him saying that they were going
to a blue and they went to a double
black diamond and I said Ben that is
literally like the nastiest prank like I
would not be friends with that person
anymore no Ben needs a new friend and
Ben saw it Ben's like a like a victim he
saw it like no he was really trying to
challenge me I'm like he's trying to
hurt you he's trying to kill you oh that
reminds me speaking of victims I watched
the dumbest [__] movie last night
what movie everyone's talking about it
may December it's that Netflix original
with Natalie Portman Julianne Moore and
Charles Melton from Riverdale and it's
Loosely B based off uh Mary Kay leria MH
you know the famous school teacher who
had an affair with her seventh grader
and then ended up marrying him and
having a bunch of kids with him she just
actually recently passed and so it's
Loosely based off of that but like the
events of the movie
aren't based on Tru true events it's
just like theame May December um I don't
understand why the movie was made I
didn't understand the point of the movie
everyone was honestly terrible except
Charles Melton he was fabulous and for
that I was happy that they made the
movie like Netflix you know giving
Charles Melton a chance in like an Oscar
what should be like an Oscar Contender
he was excellent he played um the young
student but now everyone's all grown up
so it's like they go back so they're
making a movie about Mary Kay La turna
in the movie and Natalie Portman is the
actress who's going to play Mary Kay so
she goes and spends like some time with
Mary Kay her husband her family and you
know things get crazy sounds like a good
concept that's why I watched it but it
wasn't if you ask me what happened in
the movie I don't think I could tell you
or like what the PL of the mov they love
making movies like that where it's just
like here's a bunch of footage do with
it what you will and then I of course
went went down like a Mary Kayla Chia
rabbit hole and that was interesting but
it was creepy as [__] like Ben was so
Disturbed he was like why the [__] did
you put this on I'm 0 for two with Ben
first was that documentary love has won
and now Mary Kay lard
like I got to stop I got to stop taking
recommendations from Instagram well yeah
that's your first problem yeah why don't
you watch the new lifetime Christmas
movie with Janna Kramer that has a sex
scene I think I would prefer to watch
the Hallmark Hanukkah movie with ls lit
it's called round and round it might be
lifetime actually I can't remember which
one two great options two great
options and we have a great show today
because there's stories but there's also
dear toasters which we pushed off from
yesterday we have an update from
somebody who wrote in for a very
polarizing one a couple of we weeks ago
and we've got great submission so I'm
excited I'm excited too so without
further
Ado here are the fast life stories that
you need to know and the fast five
stories that you need to know are
brought to you by drizzly drizzly is the
go-to app for drink delivery especially
during the holidays so whether you're
sending a gift from afar hosting or
attending a festive party or just
restocking your bar with some seasonally
appropriate bever appropriate beverages
you can find the right drinks for the
occasion on drizzly they've got
everything on drizzly like the good
stuff they've got Don Julio Reposado
Bullet bourbon Kettle One vodka they've
really got it all and it's going to save
you money by comparing prices on a huge
selection of beer Wine and Spirits from
local stores I've used drizzly for many
many years when I'm hosting stuff when
I'm going to a party and Ben forgot to
pick up pick up a gift I'll either send
it to my house while I'm getting ready
or I'll just send it directly to the
person's house with a little note they
handle it really well deliver is always
really seamless you can download the
drizzly app or go to drizly.com drizzly
is spelled d r i z l y.com it is our
goto app for alcohol delivery you must
be over 21 it's not available in all
locations and you can really just find
it's also a great way to discover new
products they have like great little
sections little filters seasonal items
different beers so it's a great way to
discover new products or just restock on
your faves because the holidays can be
difficult you know with all the shopping
all the errands you know your husband's
not helping you you don't need a husband
when you have drizzly that's their
official slogan so download the drizzly
app or go to drizzle.com d r i l y.com
it's the go-to app for alcohol delivery
you must be over 21 and is not available
in in all locations check out drizzly
thank you so much for sponsoring today's
episode today's episode is also brought
to you by caroway there is a gift for
everyone from Caraway share with the
people that you love the gift of Caraway
because we know that you got it for
yourself cuz we've been talking about it
for years it's the best thing on the
planet like don't get me started on that
little storage system they have for all
the lid covers I'm
obsessed obsessed nobody else could ever
but now the holiday season is there a
homemaker in your life is there a girly
you know who maybe just got married or
has a you know big obsession with cook
or is entering her balabusta era maybe
she's going to start
homesteading carway is the product for
the homesteaders the holidays are closer
than ever so make sure you order to get
their gift or yours underneath the tree
in time so why car is different is that
their products are non-toxic they're
made without any toxic Mater toxic
materials like pfas PTFE pfoa or any
other hardto pronounce chemicals it's
easy cooking also the Ceramics naturally
slick surface means that minimal oil or
butter is required for slide off the pan
eggs and easy cleaning it's well- loved
we Rave about it over 50,000 people have
raved about their carway kitchen wear
now it's time to try it for yourself you
really have to try it to understand why
it's different you're like oh what why
is this pot different from other pot
order it and you'll see also their
Storage Solutions like they have just
great products and great ways to like to
store it in your cabinet I feel like
pots and pans are just can be so chaotic
not with carway they got these little
dividers they got this little thing you
hang on the door to put your Lids in
it's so smart so visit carway home.com
theeast to take advantage of this
limited time offer for up to 20% off
your next purchase this deal is
exclusive for toasters it will not last
long so visit carway home.com toast to
get new kitchen wear before the holidays
carware Caraway non-toxic cookware made
Modern today's episode is also brought
to you by Legacy box the simple and safe
way to reclaim all the Priceless footage
that you haven't seen in years you can
get your family's videotapes camcorder
Fe reels photos you can get them all
digitized and converted for just $9 and
photos can be professionally scanned for
as low as 7 cents each which is 76% less
than what other brands charge I just had
a fabulous experience with Legacy box
because we found uh my B Mitzvah tape it
was a VHS tape because I'm old as hell
um and we obviously had no clue how to
like watch it sent it to Legacy box the
process was so easy we've used Legacy
box before but this was like really
special because I was so unbelievably
beautiful at my bot Mitzvah I had
sidebangs and I wore a yellow dress from
YSL and I just felt like that moment
needed to be preserved of course you
know me becoming a woman but also the
beauty of my youth like it really needed
to be captured Legacy box was fabulous
it's really simple and it's safe it's
the safest way to digitize your
treasured videotapes film reels and
photos everything they do is done by
hand it's done right in the US and you
can convert your media to digital cop
copies that will always be protected
from floods mold or even the decay of
time the process is so easy send in your
legacy box filled with the old tapes
their team will professionally digitize
everything by hand and you'll get it
back on the cloud or thumb drive along
with your Originals after 10 years in
business Legacy box is the world's
largest digitizer they've helped over a
million families re relive their family
memories think of all the Christmas
mornings that you've recorded now you
can spend Christmas morning watching
those recorded moments but it won't be
such a hassle because Legacy box sent it
to you on a thumb drive and thumb drives
are extremely easy to use you can
literally plug it into your computer so
Legacy box is one of the few products
that's in stock right now and ready to
ship make this holiday season Special by
giving the gift of memories get your
family's videotapes converted for just
$9 and photos will profession will be
professionally scanned for as low as 7
cents each during this exclusive
exclusive last minute holiday offer from
Legacy box go to legacybox.com toast
that's Legacy box.com
thank you Legacy box for sponsoring
today's episode that's probably the best
gift you can get someone honestly yeah
that's a great
one thank you our first story tailored
Swift celebrated her 34th birthday last
night uh at a Leal party alongside Blake
Lively and friends they did not go to
zerob bond as expected they were at a
restaurant club no we had said we had
said that we think Travis is party for
her her could be at zero Bond but he
wasn't there last night no he didn't go
to the party last night so maybe he's
throwing a party for her this weekend no
I'm so crazy like when I drive around I
drove past nou Uptown and there's like a
big tent outside I just want to put it
out there like maybe it's there or do
you think there's a chance that it's
going to be in Kansas City and he's
going to fly everyone out that would be
so cute and probably cheaper no but also
because he might not be able to leave
right Kansas City or will it just be so
cute like will it be at holiday house
after he plays the
Patriots I don't know holiday house is
like not private but it's also like how
do you play the Patriots and not stop
over at Holiday
House it would be a crime Holiday House
like is the New England Patriots I
agree so I don't know I feel like this
weekend something's a bruin cuz before
the game or after the game we this
looked nice like a fun night with
friends and she was wearing her birthday
Sparkles but it wasn't like the thing
right no it wasn't the thing but it was
like a dinner with close friends like
Blake Lively was there Sabrina Carpenter
was there I love Sabrina Carpenter being
brought into this fold I love Sabrina
Carpenter yeah I'm I also love ay being
brought into the fold because everyone
in this group is tall and representation
matters and Sabrina Carpenter is out
here like representing us and it's
really crazy how I feel like short
people stay friends with short people
and tall people stay friends with tall
people maybe it's a logistical thing you
know like I can't hear you up there yeah
right but i' love to see Sabrina
crossing over
I love and she's really short like your
friends are not tall you don't have I
have one super tall friend and I feel
like we're always having to work past it
Kristen oh Kristen is she's like but
she's like normal height but just
compared to us she's pretty she's like
average T she a tall girl she's a tall
girl like when we would take pictures
she found a tall husband good for her
when we take pictures together like it's
a problem yeah I mean I have Brian but
that's just like I can't can't even talk
about that like that's just not normal
no but like your your girl crew is
average average yeah like my friends
were all 51 and under which is crazy
that is crazy and Dana for those of you
who don't know this about Dana and
sometimes people will see like a video
of her and they'll be like is Dana
really short Dana's
wow it's she makes me look tall and when
I wear heels and I'm with Dana I'm like
What's the I'm the monster on the hill
it's very rare that like I feel tall or
that I give someone a hug I'm like oh my
God but I experience that every time I
see Dana she's tiny and just so you know
I don't like the feeling of being tall
me neither but maybe that's because it's
just unfamiliar to us I I just want to
say like we are very short whenever
people meet us they're like you're so
much shorter than I thought you we're so
short we're 5 foot like I'm 5 foot zero
I'm 5' 3/4 maybe with the bottom type
one I just want to say I'd have it no
other way I love being short me too me
too I feel like are you worried are you
worried about your son's being short
maybe no I don't worry about things that
are completely out of my control that's
so smart like what's the point and also
like Ben is six whatever one and both of
his parents are like very average
borderline short like I don't think it
has anything to do with it no it does
but you know you could always like
something Well erant jean comes in and
you just literally can't do anything
about it you can't do anything about it
except just be like a great person right
a successful person a happy person a
charismatic person and then no one will
give a [__] about how tall or short you
are look at Napoleon so focus on
yourself focus on your insides it's so
true it's so true so that's what those
are the things I can control and that's
what I focus on That's So Smart you're
so wise I'm trying I'm trying and soon
I'll be homesteading you know what I was
some so many people sent me Homesteader
accounts yesterday you know who's a
homesteader
Homestead are like Flex sort of cuz I
did see some consumer
goods
Magnolia Magnolia ashre no Joanna Gaines
I forgot her name for a second is
Magnolia's last name
ashre
yeah yeah Theo's last name was saur
Bruno is wine RB but I call him Theo
asre saur and I call him Bruno
Ash but I've never done Magnolia's first
and last name she's just not a firsty
lasty no she's a name Wonder okay but
who's a homesteader Becca
Martinez from The Bachelor Becca
arir excitement excites me yes short
hair yeah yeah yeah okay she's a very
successful influencer podcaster and
Homestead she really does it all I was
on a wormhole of her Instagram yesterday
I followed her because like I was so so
what is shead like she's making her own
bread she did this like she did this
first bath making your own bread doesn't
make you a homesteader okay fine but she
made this bath for her baby and like her
her old older children are like cutting
flowers and so she put her baby she just
had a newborn baby Ernest Ernesto and
she got like a carway pot pretty much
but it wasn't carway it was probably
like looked more like Crusade and that's
what she used to bathe her baby but she
picked all these like flowers from her
garden and put it in it was like natural
rose water bath it was quite beautiful
and and she had the older kids like
clipping the flowers for the bath like
she okay I just want to say like nothing
you've described though is giving home s
sufficient that's like homemade soap
with the flower
soap okay I guess but like bread and
flowers that's just someone with a
garden and a kitchen The Vibes were
homesteading Vibes that's probably true
yeah no it was a beautiful content I'm
so glad yeah so You' love to see a
homesteading podcaster Jackie's going to
be out here like any minute turning
better in I don't I really don't think I
will because I do not have the time to
make my own bread and we don't even eat
bread no and like bread from the store
is so good like no but like I don't even
buy bread from the store really I have
like you know a loaf in my fridge for
rainy grilled cheese day but it's not
like we utilize bread all the time yeah
not like you're like making sandwiches I
live with Ben offer so like we do often
have bread and I made a banana bread the
other week to make use of some old
bananas and like we didn't really eat it
because we don't eat banana bread I have
such a problem with banana bread I
really can't get into it because I know
I'll trigger a nation but
we need to stop there's nothing better
than a good banana bread Dana brings me
this one from Breads in the city and
it's so [__] good God Dana and this
Bakery breads she came over to my house
a little while ago and she brought me
like a little
home house Waring gift housewarming gift
and she brought me stuff from Bread's
Bakery she brought me a rugal and my
favorite pomier cookies I don't know if
I'm saying that right p a l m i e r like
I call them the elephant
ears and everyone else there was like
you don't know breads you don't know
breads I'm like no no cuz you live up up
town no but there's a bunch no it's a
downtown thing I didn't know it oh is it
it feels that way because I didn't know
it and you didn't know it well I am
obsessed I it was the best wock I'd ever
had it was so [__] good try their
banana bread and then maybe maybe you'll
see a tune well banana bread is how I
feel about carrot cake like get your
[__] fruits and vegetables out of my
desserts it can't be a dessert if
there's a fruit or a vegetable in it I
support that thinking but love carrot
cake and I love banana bread and I'm
sorry to so why don't you go eat like a
broccoli brownie like it makes no
[__] sense if it were good I would
but it isn't who knows maybe someone out
there makes a good one drop the recipe I
just don't like it okay well taylored
had her birthday oh wow wow we took that
really far um Taylor had a birthday she
looked gorina vagina um loved see oh we
were talking about Serena Carpenter
that's how we got here I loved all the
girlies being out and about I saw a
video of her getting out of the car with
Blake Lively and the tellers and the
paparazzi flash was so insane like I
just wonder what Miles Teller was
thinking you know yeah cuz he's like an
extremely famous person and I doubt
anything really phases him but I was
thinking I'm like even this must be wild
yeah I'm surprised I sunglasses because
that would really hurt my eyes but I
have sensitive eyes yeah no I was just
like how do you see what's in front of
you no you like don't it's a lot yeah
okay I'm waiting for the big
party also are you seeing all this drama
with tailored in the comedy show I'm
sure you're getting tagged in it
incessantly I am and I'm choosing to
ignore it like I I really can't I can't
yeah I just and I and I have
thoughts it's just upsetting so like
sometimes we have to no some you have to
choose your battles like I just so okay
so Taylor went to a comedy show um where
all the proceeds were going to Gaza and
there's like nothing wrong with that in
its Essence however I we all like after
learning like a lot of the aid that gets
sent to Gaza actually gets nowhere near
the civilians there and it actually ends
up in the hands of Hamas and in turn
creates weapons and just a for a
terrorist organization so that's a
concern obviously but I don't know if
you're just if you're going to get
involved now and not mention the
atrocities of October 7th and not
mention all the Jews who died and not
mention the terrorist organization not
mention the hostages which is ongoing
like that's just disappointing it really
is and Taylor is very intentional that's
and I'm not saying that in a bad way at
all she's like a very meticulous person
she cares a lot about what people think
so this was obviously like a move
because you know people have on both
sides have been disappointed in her for
not speaking out and so this was her way
of speaking out in a way that I think
she felt comfortable and that she felt
was safe and
yeah it was a tough blow I'm it was but
I'm I I don't I don't know I don't know
how to feel yeah yeah so but you also
have to keep in mind you know like who
she is super close with yeah I don't
think she has a Zionist friend I don't
think so either you know Gigi
Hadid you know Selena Gomez you know
these are not people who have
favorable opinions about Israel or the
Jews yeah so it's been it's that's
something I I deeply struggle with yeah
so I guess that's why it hasn't been a
story like what's there to say
disappointing are we at a point also
hasn't been like it hasn't been like Mig
mainstream news but like okay so are we
at a point where are you disappointed
enough to like stop being a fan of hers
and stop talking about her honestly like
talking about her every single day like
is good for our business so sure why
should we be punished no I do like but
also like this is a person I love like I
I don't know I'm sure I don't know now
you know so in case you were wondering
yeah and I was yeah are you ready for
our next story in case you were
wondering yes Oprah Winfrey has admitted
to using weight loss medication she says
she was blamed and shamed for her body
for 25 years before deciding to use a
weight loss drug so a slim down Oprah is
looking back on the emot Oprah okay is
looking back on the emotional turmoil
she faced during her decades long
struggle with her weight she said it was
a public sport to make fun of me for 25
years and she was often blamed and
shamed on her journey she said the
things that were said about me said to
me around me the jokes that were made
you could not get away with today she
talked about that landing on um Mr
Blackwell's fashion critic list early in
her career crushed her emotionally she
said I was on the cover of some magazine
and it said dumpy frumpy and downright
lumpy I just accepted that as that's
what it is and I didn't feel angry I
felt sad I felt hurt I felt shamed but
it didn't occur to me that I could even
feel angry she said I swallowed the
shame and I accepted that it was my
fault now in her people cover story
she's admitting to using a weight loss
drug not only to help her lose weight
but also to assist in maintaining her
figure she said the fact that there's a
medically approved prescription for
managing weight and staying healthier in
my lifetime feels like relief like
Redemption like a gift and not something
to hide behind and once again be
ridiculed for I'm absolutely done with
the shaming from other people and
particularly myself
that's my queen right there we were
talking about this I think you weren't
on the episode I think I hosted with
Taylor ster and Oprah was asked about
these medications and she gave just sort
of like an evasive answer and we were
saying how like we need like a face of
OIC like we need and Oprah being like
the spokes person obsessed like we
needed Oprah yeah but I feel like she
didn't say which drug she's on whether
like that's okay oh when I say OIC I'm
sorry I mean just the needles like in
general she didn't even say like she
didn't say that that that's what it is I
mean we can all glean that that is what
it is but someone had said that like
Weight Watchers
bought so yes this is also like a
business thing for Oprah Oprah is like a
majority owner of Weight Watchers and
maybe a year or two ago um Weight
Watchers bought like a tella Health
company that prescribes weight loss
drugs so it's all you know Synergy well
which I I love that and maybe she's like
waiting to drop the name until the the
ink is signed but I do think these drugs
should be more accessible for people
more affordable for people and I hope
that's what hero is here me to I
completely agree I there was a lot of
people being like d Oprah we knew like
why didn't you tell us shut the [__] up
like everybody comes to this admission
on their own everyone's journey is their
own I'm sure Oprah wanted to be like
will this even work for me like it takes
time I respect her journey I'm a like a
big big fan of her sharing and I love
this and I agree like hopefully her
getting involved with it from a business
sense like really does make it more
accessible for people more affordable it
shouldn't be as expensive as it is it
should be covered by Insurance because
weight is a health concern right and
hopefully that's her Mission here like
if there's anyone who can do it it's oer
it's oer yeah combined with Weight
Watchers I think there's major potential
so I hope that's what this is me too and
she looks great she like looks more
confident and happy like obviously her
body looks different but there's just
like an aura about her I was watching
her
on I forget what it was maybe Tik Tok
she made a Tik Tok with Gail and they
were just like walking through the
office and she's only been wearing
purple cuz she's out here promoting The
Color Purple movie and she just looked
so different not even in a physical
sense but just like the way she carried
herself like it was fabulous I'm really
happy for her yeah same and she's really
someone who's been through it like and
not only in terms of like weight
fluctuations but like she's been in the
public Eye For What 40 years
and it was at a time where like you
could say [__] that you can't say now
and like I'm sure like that cover story
that she just referred to is just like a
the ice one of many yeah yeah yeah well
our next story is some Mama news
pregnant SI Miller flaunts her baby bump
and poses with her 11-year-old daughter
Marlo for a Vogue photo shoot so she's
got the new Mom glow Sienna Miller
showed off her growing baby bump on the
cover of vogue's winter issue released
Wednesday revealing her bare Tummy in a
relaxed beach shop
seriously gorgeous photo I feel like we
were just saying that some that oh maybe
it was about Sports Illustrated how they
should like you know they had a bunch of
people on the cover and they really
covered the gamut of everyone and they
should have had a pregnant woman too
like they should have and I love that
Vogue did it and the picture is truly
beautiful also her 11-year-old
daughter's in the photos this was a
pregnancy announcement oh I guess what I
mean I don't follow her closely so I
don't know if she had announced but if
it is that's great also her boyfriend is
olly green who stars in the new season
of the crown so that's good oh that's
good biller is so Chic yeah like there's
not even a word I feel like she's this
generation's like Carolyn betet you know
she's just like on another level and
she's so not like a Fame [__] she just
like gets attention because she's that
cool yeah it's so true every movie she's
in it's like also she to me is such a
chameleon that she'll be in a movie and
I don't even realize that it's SI Miller
like the fact that she played Chris
Kyle's wife what yeah I didn't even
recognize her she was like a redhead in
that movie brunette something yeah yeah
no she's really like a very talented
actress and she got known for her like
talent and then she just happens to be
this like really stylish she doesn't
like she's not like Gody she doesn't
wear like a big Chanel purse like she's
just so understated and so simple and
Chic she's really goals like she's
she's iconic no and everything she does
is just iconic and Chic and elegant and
refined yeah but I really love this
color and I think it's a it's a great
look for for mamas and I can't believe
there was a time where Jude Law and
Sienna Miller were together and then
what he slept with the nanny
yeah like because to me that coupling
like they they might as well be brother
and sister like that's how perfect and
similar they are yeah but I also just
like they don't shock me that they were
together because like I associate the I
didn't think I knew them separately
until I knew them together but the way
that you feel about that is like how I
feel about like now Victoria Beckham and
David Beckham like yes wow couldn't have
written it any better
right well it's a story oldest time
happy for her and her daughter's name is
Marlo which I'm sure you've seen
everyone is saying to you that's Lis
lit's middle name in suits and you
should name your future pup Marlo Asos
to Shelly no I still like Shelly also
like I know someone Jessica Marlo and
like that's just what I think of when I
think Marlo mhm so I feel like I I don't
like it for a name for a puppy I also
think of the Marlo pillow what's that oh
it's um a pillow I guess you don't watch
my Instagram stories I've done a few ads
for them and it's a pillow where it's
like there's it's a one- siiz fits-all
pillow you can like Zip both sides to
make it firmer or plusher oh that's
smart yeah you don't need to go like
pressing around on pillows like it's
just the one pillow the Marlo pillow
right now I I'm enjoy I I'm I'm stuck on
Shelly but I don't know if that's the
name okay I also haven't brought it up
to Ben I could see him being like I hate
that name I don't see that for Ben he'll
support whatever you
want yeah because he doesn't really have
a choice you
know are you ready for our next story a
little more Mama news is this number
four number four yeah I'm ready Paris
Hilton say she was joking about not
changing her son's diaper for the first
month of his life so Paris Hilton had to
issue an AP well she didn't have to she
could do whatever she wants but I guess
on her show they're airing the season
now where she has her son and she goes
to change his diaper and she said um she
made a joke like this is the first
diaper that she's changed in the the
whole month of his life and I guess
people were very upset about there so
she put out an extremely long statement
um oh read it about how it was a joke
and I firmly believe her she said hey
there it's Paris just wanted to clear
the air about something on my show
parents said love I joked about changing
a diaper for the first time which let's
be honest was just me having a bit of
fun as you can see I changed his diaper
the night I brought him home but in all
seriousness when it comes to being a mom
and fully involved in loving every
moment of it it's interesting how a
playful comment can be taken so
seriously even though the season was the
most real authentic and raw I've ever
been with my fans sometimes I play into
the Whimsical charact character I
portrayed on the simple life it's a role
that's hard to shake off completely
while I love a good laugh I also believe
in being real and responsible especially
as a parent let's remember to find the
humor in life but also to cherish and
respect the real moments thanks for
understanding I actually like totally
understand her explanation like of this
like she has this like character that
she's really shed over the last few
years like we've gotten to know the real
Paris through her book and her
documentary um but it was this like
character she played for so many years
and I'm sure when the camera's in front
of her it's hard not to be like that's
hot and so I totally get it yeah I also
find like in the first month of baby's
life like the diaper the Dad's doing the
diapers like that's well that was
another thing I wanted to say but I
can't speak because I'm not a mom but
like okay let's say it was she didn't
change a diaper for the first month cuz
the kid has a dad and I'm sure an nny
like is that so bad no like I feel like
whenever like I would be with the baby
all the time and whenever it was time to
change like okay like now I can get up
and go to the bathroom or brush my teeth
or wash my face and I feel like I would
have made the same joke like oh my gosh
I have to change a diaper in two weeks
because like that was just like not my
responsibility so I I also don't feel
like it's that crazy of a thing to say
and I do think she was also joking like
even when I say oh I haven't changed
diaper in two weeks like yes I have
changed a diaper but like not a ton of
them because that's daddy Duty I also
think it's so important to remember like
when if you're going to like critique
you know on the internet someone's
parenting it's so important to remember
that fathers
exist and it's a very real thing you
know yeah yeah so don't forget about the
fathers yeah no that's like one I feel
like between diapers and also baths baby
baths that's like Dad Duty yeah because
like the baby's really on the mom so
much so that like when the the daily
things need to get done it's like oh
great now Mom can get out of bed for the
first time today right that's what we're
saying and also not the case in paris's
situation cuz she had a surrogate but
for a lot of women like we are healing
so I my back is broken I don't want to
stand over the changing table your back
you're vagina no but like to change the
first few weeks of changing diapers like
my back also that's from giving birth
but also from breastfeeding like and
epidural right yeah but I think it's
more so like the the it's the whole
thing so painful to stand over and
change the stand and do the bath like
Daddy Duty daddy literal Duty literal
Duty yeah no don't forget about the dads
yeah real don't sleep on them yeah and I
have a feeling her husband's like very
involved so yeah but I mean I literally
don't know that but I just have a
feeling but also I read an article from
them when she was doing that press about
her book right when like Phoenix was
born the I forget which cover she did
maybe it was like w magazine they were
talking about how the first few weeks of
Phoenix's life they did not have any
help they did it all themselves like
where is that
right so but I totally I respect her
explanation cuz it actually makes sense
yeah and I'm sure like her seeing like
people clowning on her for being like
she doesn't she's not a present mother
like that hurts and it's like oh [__]
okay let me explain to you fools let me
explain to you fools fools are you ready
for our fifth and final story
that is brought to you by the State Farm
personal price plan per chance yes the
State Farm personal price plan helps you
create an affordable price just for you
the plan's all about being personal to
you and your needs that means you get
the coverage you want a policy that
helps cover what's important to you and
an affordable price just for you because
after all life is just better when you
can personalize your experiences so
think about it like this from your go-to
coffee order to your favorite pair of
sweatpants we know that you love to
personalize your entire day just like we
do insurance is so so personal like I
feel like I say this every day but you
guys aren't listening insurance is so
personal so many things in life are
personal but insurance I mean take a
look at Jackie and I we are two girls
who couldn't be more similar we've
essentially had the same life experience
but even our insurance needs could not
be more different you know we live in
different states that's a big thing
Jackie is a homeowner she is dependence
she is curs I just have a c she is curs
we're so different and our insurance
should reflect that and clearly
personalization just makes everything
that much better and stay far Farm they
believe that insurance should work the
same way your plan your coverage your
selections can all be personalized to
you so like a good neighbor State Farm
is there prices vary by state options
selected by customer availability and
eligibility may vary like a good
neighbor St Farm is there like a good
neighbor State firm is there like a good
neighbor TTY is there like a good tury
State Farm is there that's better State
Farm free idea that one's for you
today's episode is also brought to you
by Squarespace the all-in-one website
platform for entrepreneurs to stand out
and succeed online whether you're just
starting out or managing a growing brand
Squarespace makes it easy to create a
beautiful website engage with your
audience and sell anything from products
to content to time all in one place all
on your terms so whatever your reasoning
might be for wanting to start a website
there is never a bad time it's never too
late so get started with Squarespace so
you could say t i don't need a website
really you do there's a million reasons
you know are you an artist a graphic
designer a videographer a photographer
you want to show showcase your work
online have a great like digital
portfolio so you can book bookings you
can do that with Squarespace you can
create an asset Library we can upload
organize and access all your content
from one place with the new asset
Library you're able to manage all your
files from one Central Hub and then use
them across the Squarespace platform if
you work in e-commerce you want to start
a side business like a little side site
you can sell custom merch you create an
online store they have really flexible
website templates so get started with
one of their professional website
templates with designs for every
category and use case then customize
your look update your content and add
features that fit your unique needs the
best part I think about Squarespace is
that if you have an e-commerce website
or you sell things online like merch or
trinkets whatever it might be but then
you also want to sell in person they
have a point of sale where you can sell
in person by connecting a square reader
to the Squarespace app and you'll be
able to keep all your orders inventory
and customer data in sync with your
online store so head to squarespace.com
for a free trial and when you're ready
to launch go to squarespace.com toast to
save 10% off your first purchase of a
website or a domain that's
squarespace.com toast to save 10 % off
your first purchase of a website or a
domain today's episode is also brought
to you by well professionals well
professionals has over 140 years of
experience developed initially for for
professional use only and previously
only being sold in salons it is
consistently ranked among the top loved
Brands by professional stylist and their
new line the ultimate repair is the most
premium line to date it was developed
with over 140 years of experience and
research to deliver the very best
Miracle Hair rescue repairs hair in only
90 seconds so the ultimate repair
Miracle Hair rescue is my favorite
product to use on wet hair I get a lot
of questions because my hair is like
styled almost every day and that's a lot
of heat to be putting on your hair so I
use products that really kind of protect
and repair my hair and the Miracle Hair
rescue from well is my favorite product
it's super easy douse your hair in it I
do like 10 15 pumps while my hair is wet
let it sit minimum 90 seconds sometimes
I do more but I never do less and then I
just style my hair as normally and
there's a visible difference in my hair
it's shiny it looks healthy I love this
product it also just smells really
really good and when when I work out I'm
like always now really like
self-conscious about how my hair smells
and this product really helps so this
luxury product has Rich textures and
floral scents and it is designed for all
hair types and textures it's the perfect
luxury leave-in spray treatment that
everyone can benefit from so I love that
it's easy to apply I can leave it in all
day it's also safe on colored hair and
it can be applied right after you towel
dry your hair so you can try ultimate
repair Miracle Hair rescue with 10% off
the travel size on Amazon by using promo
code 10 toast so shop the travel size of
the ultimate repair Miracle Hair rescue
on Amazon and use promo code 10 toast
that's one Z toast thank you la you're
welcome our fifth and final story a
little rumored new couple
news RN CN Drake and Camila Cabo cozy up
in Turks and koos with jet skis and a
boat ride a source says he digs her vibe
so Drake and Camila Cabo were spotted
flirtatiously chatting while vacationing
in Turks and caos according to videos
obtained and posted on dumois they were
seen giggling and standing close as they
let LC on a rickety boat that was tagged
at the No Frills outdoor dive the
rickety boat outdoor Dive Bar Noah's Arc
Beach Club the sress was dressed in a
black one piece bathing suit while he
opted for blue tie-dye muscle tea and
shorts there was also a picture of them
on jet skis separate skis but like next
to each other so they're on a vacation
together um there's no pictures of them
kissing or touching but they're on a
trip together which is kind of crazy The
Source says she was with a friend and he
was only paying Camila
attention I know but like these pictures
are so platonic yeah there's no sexiness
like and maybe like the sexiness is just
hasn't been captured or they're kind of
like courting each other and they're not
doing PDA right now you Court you Court
someone by taking them on vacation
celebrities are just different from us
they are but like I feel like for any
human being like when you go on vacation
it's cuz like you already have a
connection with someone you know yeah
I'm going to need a little more to
believe this is what I'm saying even
though yes technically it's like right
in front of me and they're together on
vacation I know but historically like
celebrities on Yachts like that's where
we've gotten like iconic sexy photos of
course who remembers Harry and Kendall
laying on that yacht like we always I
feel like vacation is where you're very
sexy and touchy and in the ocean and
you're in a bathing suit and you're
naked like I don't know it's giving
friends as stated it was a rickety boat
that they were on like I'm watching the
video and it's not like a yacht we're
lounging and we're just like lost in
each other they're like on a a party
boat sort of thing that's not the vibe
Cruise a it's a boo screws literally so
they're just like talking and having you
know doing their courtship I think if
there's touchy feeling this if there is
it's happening later or before I just
need more that's all I'll say I agree
but let's talk about the potential
coupling and what our thoughts would be
I feel like she's how old is she she's
26 and he's
37 appropriate some like I like it I
feel like he dates younger I feel like
he doesn't really date like famous
people of course we know Rihanna but I
feel like every girl he's like spotted
with or um it's always like someone on
like an Instagram model or yeah not a
star per se yeah so I like this I like
it too I hope it's
true he deserves love can we talk about
camil Cabo's friendship with Taylor
Swift like where did that
go I'm sure it's just lying
dormant I don't think there's beef I
think just Camila it's you know hard to
pin down really yeah I don't like where
does she
live La does she for sure I don't know I
feel like she just kind of does her own
thing I know I know she lives in LA but
her half her heart is in
Havana yeah I just feel like she's
taking some Camila time okay and she's
not like Swift pounding the pavement
with taylored but Drake and Taylor are
like close so like this maybe she set
them up yeah I think it's all good like
I think just Camila like sometimes makes
herself scarce and then other times like
you she's inescapable she has every song
on the radio is Camila Cabo like I think
she comes in
waves she does come in waves there was a
time where like you could not get away
from camil Cabo and her music is just
pervasive like when she chooses to
engage with the world and I feel like
sometimes she just likes to honestly I
feel like she kind of has a healthy
balance I feel like maybe she's Meredith
Marsing and disengaging for now for
now so I would ship if there is a ship
that's not a rickety boat it's also just
so interesting
the the highs and lows almost because I
was thinking the other day about Shawn
Mendes how like there was a time where
he was like the biggest star in the
world and he's still super famous but
like where in the world is Shawn Mendes
maybe like his afor mened love he comes
in waves yeah which I think is good take
time for yourself don't always be like
promoting touring writing singing like
take your time burn out enjoy your life
enjoy The Spoils of everything that
you've worked for yeah actually just was
watching this video of CA she did zann
low and she he was like what else do you
want to do and she was like honestly
like nothing like I've won Grammys I've
met Beyonce like I've worked with
everyone like what's with this like
insatiable hunger like I'm good my I've
gotten to take my parents all around the
world it was so refreshingly healthy
yeah and I was like yeah and you know
what that's what I see like C is not
always doing the most everywh number one
but she's just is popular because of her
talent and like that's enough for her
and it was honestly so refreshing like
outside of this like insane hustle
culture yeah and she's another one when
she puts out an album like all her songs
are everywhere on the radio and that's
great and then sometimes we don't hear
from her cuz she's enjoying when she
puts out music she's not like on The
Today Show GMA every she just puts it
out promotes it a little bit different
from any other artist cuz she's in it
for like the love of the music like she
could just write songs put them out and
we literally don't even see her she's
had Montana so she's not like everyone
else but I do think it's a really
healthy mentality that others should try
and emulate but I also think that's
something that's innate you know you
can't teach someone that no and some
people who are always hungry and
striving for the next thing will always
feel that way and it will never be
enough for them and it's sad sometimes
but sometimes you learn that lesson the
hard way yeah cuz then you look back on
the times when you thought you didn't
have enough and you're like if only I
could get back to that exactly but but
then the people who are always like
striving and wanting to achieve can
accomplish really great things that
maybe the people who are like this is
enough for me diu don't yes there's two
sides to every coin is what we're saying
and what we're also saying is that those
were the Fast Five but we're far from
done because we have deer toasters our
weekly advice segment so once a week we
will take three submissions from the
girlies who need help from us and if you
want to submit you can do so in one of
two ways you can go to the toast
podcast.com scroll down a little bit
there's a little submission box it's
totally Anonymous try and keep it brief
if you've written Us in and we haven't
read it it might be too long and then
you can also email us dear toasters
gmail.com we'll keep it Anonymous of
course so our first one I am writing in
oh sorry Hi Jackson Claud I am writing
in because I recently lost a ton of a
weight a ton of weight thanks OIC before
starting OIC I gave all my cute designer
clothes that didn't fit me anymore to my
best friend because they were too good
to go to waste and I never thought I'd
lose the weight or be able to get Auto
epic the clothes are not things I can
just Reby for myself they were all
high-end designer that I've collected
over the years now that I'm back to my
wa size I really want those clothes back
I recently saw her and she was wearing a
pair of my expensive pants and I
mentioned how those probably would fit
fit me now she said hm and moved on from
the conversation should I just flat out
flat out ask for my closet back yes yeah
send like a really sweet text being like
hey um I was so like happy to give you
those things when I thought they would
no longer fit me but I've lost the
weight and I would love to get back into
some of them if you you know if you
still have them could I how do you say
can I get it back and like you could
just say it honestly if this is a true
friend like she'll be happy for you and
we'll be grateful for the year she got
with clothes she didn't have to pay for
like I'm sorry if she says no she's
psychotic and just be
like hey Christian I don't know I was
just thinking about all the clothes I
gave you like last year and how they'd
probably fit me now and I'm so excited
about that possibility and I'm wondering
if you'd be able if I can come pick them
up like make it easy for her don't be
like can you drop them off be like can I
come pick them up like I really want to
try them on and see if any of them fit
me cuz I've been dying to wear them for
so long like just make it about you and
then of course make the picking up
process easy cuz don't give her a job be
like can you drop it off at my building
yeah yeah do it though do it I mean the
worst thing that happens is she says no
and you've lost a friend but I think
it's worth you should do it I mean and
it's literally like money and clo like
it's yours snatch it snatch it this next
one is
so interesting dear Jackson lurd I
became a toaster over a year ago and my
life is forever changed I'm writing in
for some wedding planning advice I'm
getting married in June to a peom and we
are so excited we're in the thick of
wedding planning and we recently found
out that another couple from the town we
grew up and is getting married at our
venue the night before our wedding I
went to high school with the bride but I
wasn't friendly with her and she's a few
years younger than me she dm'd me very
nicely talking about how we're both
getting married at the same venue let
alone the same weekend she then inquired
if we wanted to go in on flowers
together for the tables at the venue
since we're going to have back-to-back
weddings is this weird that she wants to
share some of the flowers 50/50 or is
this financially responsible considering
while planning a wedding in this day and
age thanks so much for booing me daily
forever sincerely a forever toaster
that's not the worst idea I've ever
heard it's not my only concern was that
like the flowers might get like
destroyed or wilted at her event people
are drunk people take flowers home
people like from weddings she'll get
like the best of the flowers and but
sometimes like they sit on the
centerpiece of the table nobody touches
them and they're still good the next day
sometimes I think she should pay 60% I
was just going to say that I think
there's nothing wrong do you think
there'll be a lot of crossover at your
wedding even if there is there's a way
to like have the same flowers but dress
up other things differently like if
you're doing your Different Linens and
like it just you could have different
lighting it just would look different
people aren't going to be that eagle
eyed no and the money you would spend
you can either save it or you can spend
on more Decor I like this this premise
honestly and I want you guys kind of
Genius yeah and if you don't want to do
it then you could just say no but like I
think it's worth inquiring and seeing if
she'll pay a little more because they
will be fresher for her yeah no but it's
also kind of like amazing that I feel
like nobody gets this yeah and that's
not what I thought the predic was going
to be wedding venues on Saturday they
bring in all this stuff gone by Saturday
night Sunday all this stuff it's so
wasteful so if you happen to know the
person it's kind
of no you guys are kind of turning the
industry on its head yeah this could be
like a really good business idea for
like people who connect people in towns
who are having like weddings back to
back yeah but I agree that that you
should pay a little bit less because
you're getting it second and you never
know I mean I see like you know always
at weddings like the old lady leaving
with three centerpieces in her car like
okay yeah you never know and you have to
be prepared for that but if you just
save 60% on your flowers then okay I
could live with that I think this is
Major yeah I think you should do it
Innovative um I have one more and then
I'll do a because this one's just like a
short deer toaster and it's so funny
longtime listener first time emailer
import question for you both what
position are we reading in is there some
sort of magic reading pillow or couch
that I am missing I know you're both
slaying the the good read goals so you
must have found a comfortable position
signed a toaster with a sore neck it's a
good question oh my neck isn't sort it's
my hands it's it definitely is hard to
get a good position what I've recently
been doing because I have a big Kindle
is I lay in bed on my back with my
pillows like up on my neck I put my legs
up my knees are like
this and then I lay the Kindle on my
knees oh that's okay I sometimes if I'm
reading like not under the covers I'll
sit up I actually sometimes put my
nursing pillow on my lap so it's like a
rest for my Kindle in my hands it's my
wrists that hurt the most not my neck
and then a lot of times I read like with
the lights off under the covers and I'm
on my side and then I switch sides I'm
on my side a lot too when I read and I
think that's helpful yeah but can we
talk about how unbelievably tortures it
is to read a physical book like
especially if you're at the way
beginning or the way end like with the
way the pages lay flat like I I just I
like I'm always like breaking the neck
of my book so it like lays even it's so
annoying Kindle Kindle cuz when you're
reading a book there's always like the
right side is always comfortable modern
solutions for an archaic
problem you said it that would be funny
if that was our title today the invert
inverse yeah of two days ago our third
and final dear chers is an update so I'm
going to read her original submission
found you guys on Tik Tok I need advice
in a bad way I was going through my
boyfriend's phone and came across a
picture I took of one of my friends in a
bathing suit that was on my camera roll
it was never on a social media platform
the photo even said live in the top
corner I asked him about it and he
claimed he screenshotted it off of
Instagram which I debunked immediately
because it was never posted he gave no
further explanation for himself and
denied it that he denied that he saved
it for my camera roll which was the only
place that the picture existed I don't
think I was here this day that this was
submitted because I'm in shock over this
yeah oh so I'm not sure how to move
forward with this information XOXO I
turned off toaster I feel like I have
like a memory of reading this with you
now no I've never heard this before so
isn't it crazy like the live photo like
he literally went on her phone to
clearly sent it to himself I'm in shock
what I don't know what you advised but
read the update ready hey girls I'm the
one that wrote in about her boyfriend
sending himself a picture of uh off my
phone of my friend in a bikini I just
wanted to let you know that I found out
they had been sleeping together the
entire time girlfriend intuition to go
through the phone never fails you were
correct yeah what we said was like why
were you going through this phone in the
first place place you know what came
first the chicken or the egg you
obviously had a reason for snooping like
I always hate for my like it my response
or my advice to be like this is the
reddest of flags and like you can't be
with this person if he's like looking up
a bikini photos of your
friend I I'm glad that solved itself
yeah damn double homicide losing a
friend and a boyfriend no you saved
yourself time friendship that you don't
have to get drinks with this ly cheating
[__] you don't have to
you know think about a future with him
time equals saved no but you're right
like when we read these things like the
inclination is always be like this is a
big red flag get rid of this loser I
know you tell everyone to break up with
their boyfriends no and like sometimes
like people do things that are bad but
like you have to work through it and
like I feel like we see this all the
time on shows and stuff where like
someone will cheat and it's like yeah
you need to break up with a cheater but
like they work through it and it's
better and it's good so like sometimes
the advice isn't to break up I know also
somebody I think post posted this in one
of our Facebook groups and it's so funny
like literally every time we do a dearer
toaster is about someone's boyfriend
they write in like I've been with my
fiance for 3 years total P Jam they
always call him P jam and then they
continue to write like the most vile
atrocious thing that this person did and
it's like so funny I know and when I
hear that at the beginning of a dear
toaster it's like my fiance total P jum
he's the best then whatever the thing
that's going to come after is I'm like
oh well he's a p Jam he's the best so
that thing after like we're going to I'm
going to clean it up for you because
he's obviously a good person but maybe I
need to be questioning that initial
judgment never stop asking
why yeah that always complicates things
like oh it's it's a peam but he has a
picture of your friend in a bikini but
he's a p jom but he's but he's a p j
maybe he's going to like buy you that
bikini cuz he thought did she call him a
pum no she didn't call him a pom in this
one so what did she say how long were
they
together just called him her that's also
relevant information if you've been
together whether 6 months or a year like
I will more likely advise break up with
him if it's like a seven-year this is
your um long-term partner and you guys
are in a common-law marriage like I
might want to work through some things
yeah of course we'll give it more effort
we'll save it yeah but when I hear
boyfriend I'm like he could go yeah
boyfriend not anymore so that's dear
toasters don't forget to submit your
submission at dear toasters at gmail.com
or head over to the toast podcast.com
this was our second to last episode of
the week tomorrow's episode
episode of the year of the year don't
miss it tomorrow's going to be sad
emotional reflective final final so
thank you guys so much for listening to
the toast the millennial Morning Show
where we deliver the past five stories
that you you need to know every Monday
through Friday on YouTube so if you're
watching us on YouTube please feel free
to subscribe and give this video a
thumbs up we're also available as
podcast anywhere podcast can be found
set Spotify iTunes Stitcher public radio
I Heart Radio cast box all the places R
you listen to podcast find us to toast
leave a five star review about a
beautiful stunning and wickedly talented
we are hope you guys have an amazing day
we'll see you tomorrow 4 Friday Friday
got to get down on Friday love you bye
love you
bye